I'm a small business owner that depends
on the Royal Mail to deliver my online
sales I've lost thousands because of
these strikes at a time that we
desperately need the sales to pay our
bills why is it okay for you to not
accept a perfectly reasonable deal while
we suffer is what Casey says well the
first thing Katie is is that you know we
don't want to see your business
suffer in that weight but what I'd say
to you is is that what royal Mal are
doing will destroy the service that you
like and that you want forever that's
the reality of it there's not a
reasonable deal on the table I've
already explained that I've not even
spoken about pay at this point I think
the vast majority of our members are
terrified now of losing their job that
is what we're facing that is what the
company
well for what they call modernization
yes so what the company wants to do is
to start deliveries up to three hours
later they're asking us to sign up to
that and what we're saying is is that's
part of a wider plan to end daily
deliveries in Royal Mail it's back to
the point I said so you think that
they're not interested in the way yeah
definitely like they want to move to a
separate parcel company on the lowest
possible terms and conditions that's
what this dispute is really about on pay
the company keeps saying that they've
offered our members nine percent uh they
have an often nine percent it's not true
if they if they'd offered they've
offered seven percent that's not fully
backdated at all so it's not the real
value of seven percent and they've
offered a 500 pound lump sum and they
say that that's worth 400 million pounds
over 18 months well we're doing costings
on that 400 million pounds and if it was
fully uh the value of 400 million pounds
in an 18-month period We Believe we'd be
very close to reaching an agreement on
pay the problem that we've got is that
we are now facing this huge assault on
our members jobs it's not justified it
is being done because this company of
grossly mismanaged their finances they
made 758 million pounds profit back in
May and in a matter of weeks they are
losing over a million pounds a day
that's not the fault of postal workers
that's the thought of the people at the
top of the company who gave 567 million
pounds to shareholders they knew all of
these issues with the economy with the
market that we operating were coming in
didn't stop them saying shareholders you
have 567 million pounds record bonuses
to the CEO
um and they've ended the cross subsidy
so they own an international company
that made over 400 million pounds and
unlike Deutsche Post the German post-op
with sunlight uh the past the French
post office who would have used that
money
to support and grow the infrastructure
of the services in their own country our
leaders give it away to shareholders
okay and they vended that cross subsidy
what we're saying okay they are
deliberately creating this situation to
drive through unacceptable change